somebody else at a crossroads for an
entirely different reason I should say
our own Cameron Mathison with a new
can-can challenge Nancy this is the
thing I thought if Andrew Zimmern you
could eat Bizarre Foods then so guy
right if you know it turns out it's one
of those ideas that sounded a lot better
in my head
we're gonna start right here in
Minneapolis a fall at the Munk town
marketplace now the thing is I know that
I can handle everything that Eddie's
gonna throw at me but the big question
is whether my stomach can we're gonna go
over to the food hall okay we're gonna
put you to the test oh boy the menu at
the marketplace changes daily so what we
were about to eat was a surprise even
for Andrew time to order some chow we're
getting the fermented pork sausage
fun fact fermented means practically
rotten which Andrew admits even he found
tough take early in his career I just I
had trouble taking a bite or two and
later on I've developed quite a taste
for it so it was time for me to take the
first step in my culinary misadventure
that too much sauce I wouldn't take that
much
[Music]
that's course a turkey tail I am about
to dig into the rear end of a turkey
patty in gelatins turns out him about
man
so far so good going into our next stop
Andrews favorite place in Minneapolis
the family-owned crane restaurant for
the grand finale this is a pig's foot
and everything on here is edible except
for the bone mm-hmm and I'm going in
[Music]
proud of him at this point
it's up to you really was this a cam cam
or a cam pant you're cold it's a big cam
cam I was paying for it on the flight I
gotta be honest I'm pretty careful what
I eat normally and I was tasty but it
got so you won't be coming over to a
house for tripe and pig feet huh no
that's not gonna be happy